chir on passe au débat du jour on va
revenir sur cette polémique autour de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est toujours un
succès ce weekend le fondateur de la
France insoumise a posté un tweet dans
lequel il sen prend violemment la
journaliste Ruth elkef qui a été une des
pionnières de BFM TV qui travaille
désormais sur LCI et c'est d'ailleurs
après une séquence tendue sur LCI entre
Ruth elkef et manuel bonpard de la LFI
au sujet de la situation proche orient
que Jean-Luc ménlenchon sonen est pris
violemment à rutelcriev sur X on regarde
la séquence en question et vous verrez
dans un instant le tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a valu à la journaliste
d'être placé ce matin sous protection
police regardez vous n'avez pas reconnu
le caractère terroriste de l'attaque du
7 octobre vous n'avez pas montré
d'empathie particulière j'ai dénoncé les
crimes de guerre et les actes de terreur
qui ont été commis et j'ai demandé
depuis le premier jour in cesser le feu
la libération des otages la fin des
bombardements israéliens sur la bande de
Gaza mais si vous l'avez pas entendu
c'est que vous avez mal lu si vous
voulez qu'on débatte de ce sujet on en
débat sérieusement ce qui se passe à
Gaza est un massacre de masse vous
pouvez considérer que ce n'est pas grave
peuttre PZ considérer c'est
uneortioné c'est extrêmement grave et ça
doit être condamné moi je n'ai pas de
propos à géométrie variable donc
maintenant plutôt que des polémiques
ridicules mettons tous nos efforts dans
la même direction c'estàd faire en sorte
que c Massac s'arrête et que la paix qui
arrive soit enfin une paix juste et dur
alors
bon derrière Jean-Luc mélchon juste
après la sé je MCH a posté ce message
envers la journaliste que c'est pas très
violent je
trouve manipulatrice si on n'injurie pas
les musulmans cette fanatique s'indigne
quelle honte bravo manuel bpard pour la
réplique elle criait frédu toute la vie
politique à son mépris des musulmans
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez 6 minutes
d'abord soutien total à Rutel crief je
pense qu'en fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
pris le prétexte de cette interview deu
pas là franchement parce que la veille
il y avait l'émission qu quelle époque
avec Léa Salamé où il il y a eu un un
diaporama avec sa photo des
éditorialistes qui ont parlé de lui
Donel CRIF et il n'a pas goûté ce qui
s'était dit sur lui et donc je pense
qu'il a saisi cette opportunité pour y
aller euh moi je comprends pas la dérive
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon plutôt je la
comprends trop bien euh il il vise la
fracture il vise le chaos et euh pour se
faire en l'occurrence là il met une
cible sur le dos d'une d'une journaliste
il a toujours dit que il aimait le
combat qu'il aimait le fight qu'il
aimait la bagarre y compris avec les
journalistes il les a toujours aussi
secoué mais là ça va vraiment trop loin
c'est c'est là pour coup ce qui fait est
dangereux alors Gill alors je suis
d'accord sur toute l'analyse de Valérie
c'est-à-dire que mais j'ai j'ai un met
que je vais citer après alors bien
entendu on peut pas placer une CPE sur
une journaliste elle est elle est sous
protection citer un nom c'est une erreur
politique majeur il faut pas faire ça en
revanche il peut faire de la politique
et il a le droit de dire aussi que sur
les plateau en ce moment il y a une
haine antimusulman il y a un manque de
dénonciation des massacres de Gaza et ça
c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire mais c'est s
noyé par son erreur stratégique de citer
une dame une journaliste que l'on
apprécie ou pas mais qui a une longue
carrière et qui ne faisait que son
boulot donc erreur là-dessus en revanche
je pense que LFI et beaucoup de gens en
ont marre de la non déénnonciation de ce
qui se passe à Gaza voilà et il pèteent
les plombs mais c'est une erreur
Géraldine euh alors moi je trouve que
comme d'habitude le tweet de Monsieur
Mélenchon est absolument obsène euh
alors d'abord on peut on peut le revoir
voilà alors déjà fanatique et
manipulatrice c'est très très fort mais
en plus il y a une sorte de
sous-entendue comme il avait fait avec
la la présidente de de l'Assemblée
nationale qui donc campa à téavive comme
quoi en fait elle réduisait toute la vie
politique à son mépris des musulmans
donc en fait ça veut dire que en gros
une femme juive donc déteste les
musulmans donc c'està-dire que lui il
est vraiment pour la bordélisation il
est pour la fracture il est pour les
deux camps qui s'affrontent il est pour
le face à face il est pas du tout pour
le vivre ensemble contrairement à ce
qu'ils nous disent et c'est lui qui
fracture et c'est lui qui stigmatise je
su désolé lui fa pas il fait pas
République il parle pas au citoyens il
dit d'un côté il a les musulmans et si
vous êtes les musulmans vous êtes avec
moi parce que les Juifs ne vous aime pas
c'est ça qui dit à travers ce tweet
c'est super grave et en plus petite
petit supplément Rutel keV a déjà été
menacé de mort par CELI ce enfin le
terroriste qui avait assassiné les gens
enfin les policiers à magnonville et
elle avait on avait retrouvé donc dans
les dans les vidéos de ce terroriste
islamique des une vidéo avec des noms
dont rout CRIF et elle était déjà sous
protection policière donc soit Monsieur
Mélenchon ne le sait pas et c'est un peu
incompétent soit il le sait et c'est
encore plus ignoble parce que c'est une
deè mise à mort et une deuxième ce sur
le sur le dos de de Madame alors il y a
une autre vidéo qui a fait énormément
parler vous allez nous dire ce que vous
en pensez et si vous comprenez que qu' a
des gens qui qui ét choqués et qui a eu
énormément de tweet derrière c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a fait un
discours qui a fait beaucoup ce weekend
c'est son discours regardez
manifestation ou j'avais juste oublié
dire un truc de la même manière
a dit des trucs que je condamne moi et
que je trouve ignoble mais pour autant
on n pas pas le menacer on n pas
l'intimider on n pas à le suiv et voilà
il doit pas être non plus lui sous
protection policière aujourd'hui les
journalistes c'est juste hallucinant
c'estàd que c'est juste ils sont
beaucoup trop fragilisés par les prise
de parole je condamne les le point de
vue de Patrick CEN mais on n' pas le
menacer évidemment je condamne
évidemment le TW de Mélanchon et on n
pas enfin voilà c'est juste n'importe
quoi
regardezit conscience éveillé ayez pour
vous la gloire de la protestation nous
pouvons dire à la suite de
l'omu qu'il y a des prémisses de
génocide c'est-à-dire de volonté
d'exterminer la totalité de la
population dont personne ne veut ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre peuple rebelle tu es
le peuple humain qui témoigne à cet
instant vive Gaza gloire éternelle à
ceux qui résistent
alors on vaevenir donc sur le tweet
également qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
moi ce discours là pour le coup pour ou
contre mais c'est de la politique là
pour moi il est dans son rôle
c'est-à-dire que c'est le
tribin très énervé en ce moment c'est
sûr mais c'est le tribin qui est d'un
côté il l'a dit depuis le début donc on
peut ne pas être d'accord on peut
condamner mais pour moi il fait de la
politique att continue sa ligne de
fracture quand il dit gloire éternelle à
à ceux qui résistent il continue à
estimer qu'il s'agit là d'un résistance
et et pas d'un groupe islamiste
terroriste Daniel moi je reviens sur le
tweet parce que parce qu'en fait j'ai
regardé toute le l'émission j'ai trouvé
Rotel CRIF très bien et elle elle a fait
son boulot comme tous les autres qui ont
interviewé elle a essayé de faire dire à
des gens de LFI que c'est un mouvement
terroriste et pour et bizarrement
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait ce tweet sur
route et criief juive donc moi je suis
désolé mais c'est c'est dans la lignée
et vous le voyez dans la il se tient là
pendant qu'il fait sa sa la tribune ben
il a il fait bien de se tenir parce que
la chute est proche parce que il est à
73 % et c'est le plus l'homme politique
le plus détesté en ce moment 73 %
détestés si ouais mais siil fait 27 %
c'est énorme oui non mais 73 % détesté
ça fera pas 27 % aux élections à mon
avis% c'est énorme c'est comme c'est
comme Annie dalgo 73 % mais pour
d'autres raisons moins graves parce que
bon Paris c'est embêtant mais voilà et
il est devant Zemmour qui est à 72 %
seulement de dé testation donc je pense
qu'il a choisi une mauvaise ligne il
s'enlise et là en ciblant une une
journaliste comme par hasard juive et
lui mettre vraiment une cible comme ça
et être obligé moi je trouve ça
gravissime vraiment il est dans une
voilà dans une spirale infernale moi je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait choisi une
mauvaise oui mais je pense que ils sont
très calculateurs ils ont fait des
calculs démographiques ils ont fait des
calculs des banlieux contre les
campagnes des banlieux contre les villes
et cetera et cetera je pense que s'il
continue sur cette ligne c'est parce
qu'il a des bonnes raisons de penser que
cette fracture cette ligne de fracture
elle existe dans ce pays et je pense
qu'il espère ramasser la mise électorale
ce qui me gêne c'est qu'évidemment il
est totalement dans l'outrance c'est
queil y a aucune limite dans l'outrance
toutes les semaines tous les 15 jours ça
va encore plus loin moi je je crains que
la France insoumise est un jour du sang
sur les mains lorsqu'on commence à s'en
prendre à une journaliste qui pour le
coup a été je suis de ton avis Daniel
parfaitement factuelle sa question c'est
enfin le fait que LFI n''estit pas
montré d'empathie à l'égard des femmes
mutilées ou violées est un fait
incontestable c'est quand même
comm dit tout àéch avec bon est sur une
lignetique très
bien défend à fond les Palestiniens pas
de problème ils
ontoit ils sont depuis le début sur
cette idée que les Palestiniens il faut
les défendre parce que de toute façon
Israël dans une dans une logique qu'
conteste bon très bien et de de colonies
et ce et ce mais de là à s'en prendre à
des journalistes de là à s'en prendre
maintenant à quelque chose qui dépasse à
mon avis l'entendement je pense qu'ils
sont en train de basculer j'ai j'ai peur
le terme est bien choisi il y a quelque
chose d'irresponsable dans l'action de
de VE dans la stratégie de l'
bordéisation ça va toujours plus loin
avec eux c'éta à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui il y avait un député enfin
l'autre jour il y avait un député de la
France insoumise qui en est venu au main
ils sont dans dans dans cette stratégie
là en
fait
ça devent chiant Bernard Montiel non
mais on sait très bien ils sont même
carrément antirépublicains je crois des
gens comme comme eux ils sont réubl tu
dis du tweet le tweet est scandaleux
inadmissible évidemment mais je veux
dire que ces gens-là sont des gens très
dangereux pour la République parce
qu'ils sont en train de créer le chaos
de sommer la division et et mais ça
c'est toi c'est toi qui dit regarde Gill
il a pas trouvé donc voilàattendais de
pouvoir répliquer antirépublicain là
vous parlez oui vous parlez de de
Monsieur Mélançon ou auierour
antirépublain il ne cherche que le
bordel il ne cherche que le bordel alors
qu'on a besoin d'être uni en ce moment
que c'est très compliqué que le conflit
israélo-palestinien est très compliqué
qui divise malheureusement les gens et
c'est bien dommage est à eux qui souffl
sur les braises uniquement non pas pour
des valeurs morales pas le vent qui
souffle sur les oui qui souffle sur les
braises
ah oui c'est vrai le vent souffle sur
les plaines de la Bretagne amainne merci
sur les braises aussi sur les Brais
aussi et au lie d'essayer calmer le jeu
ou d'arranger les choses et ils y vont
ils y vont et c'est au dieux de leur
part qui veut réagir Ron c'est pas le
bon calcul moi il m'intéresse pas mais
quand il a dit la République c'est moi
il a tout dit et là quand il crie je le
vois crier sur sur son camion là je sais
pas ce que c'est je me ditétait dans un
camion à pizza non mais je sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'il fait de penser de
penser de penser que les gens d'en bas
de penser que les gens des banlieu de
pensz que les gens les petits gens je
sais pas comment ils appellent ça la
France d'en bas comme disent les gens de
chez France de penser que ces gens-l
vous pouvez les manipuler c'est une
grave erreur parce que ces gens-l vous
pourrez pas les manipuler pas parce que
ouais mais c'est sérieux moi je parle
sérieux
je regarder ce qu'on m'a dit de dire
mais je
sé de penser qu'on peut manipuler le
vote musulman les mecs ils savent ce
qu'ils vont voter c'est c'est une grave
erreur pour moi il fait une grave erreur
en allant sur ce terrain là on veut tous
la paix à Gaza on la veut tous la p ça
ça fait plaisir à personne et de penser
de d'aller là-dedans de dire regardez
eux c'est les méchants ils veulent
bombarder Gaza nous on est les gentils
tu verras en disant il faut pas impor va
se ramasser il va se ramasser il va se
ramasser à crier comme ça il va se
ramasser ramasser descend ton camion dis
des trucs sages alors le ministre de
l'intérieur a été invité sur BFM il a
annoncé qu'il avait dû remettre une
protection policière à Rutel CRIF
regardez Monsieur Mélenchon et dans
l'irresponsabilité je l'ai vu se
comporter avec votre confrère Rutel CRIF
il met une cible dans le dos de Madame l
CRIF qui avait déjà a eu beaucoup de
menaces en tant que journaliste elle
faisait son son métier qu'elle soit une
bonne mauvaise journaliste pour Monsieur
Mélenchon c'est pas le sujet euh c'est
une démocratie les journalistes font ce
qu'ils souhaitent et ils interrogent
comme ils veulent les hommes ou les
femmes politiques donc j'ai décidé ce
matin vu les menaces que Monsieur
Mélenchon et d'autre puisque c'est un
déchaînement de haine sur internet de
remettre une protection policière à
votre conceur voilà où on en est dans le
comportement irresponsable de la France
insoumise qu'est-ce que vous en pensez g
alors Monsieur Darmanin il a raison de
pointer et je le faisais modestement
aussi le fait que Monsieur mélenchant
accroche une CPE sur une journaliste ça
c'est pas bien après monsieur Darmanin
fait de la politique vous allez
peut-être me permettre de dire décisions
prend des décisions
Mo pourquoi les autres tout le monde
fait de la politique c'est son métier
oui qu'est-ce tu c oui mais oui au MO au
moins geréral Darmanin il a un rôle non
mais Jean luuc Mélenchon il il a aucun
rôle Géral Darmanin il est ministre de
l'Intérieur donc il prend des décisions
il a pris la décision de remettre r tel
CRIF sous protection policière en tout
cas Géral darmanant il bosse B et c'est
très bien c'est très dommageable qu'on
en arrive là ça je l'ai dit tout de
suite c'est le préambule mais ensuite
c'est vrai que Monsieur Darmanin détruit
là il essaie de détruire politiquement
Monsieur Mélenchon et ça c'est de la
politique voilà moi chacun non mais je
dire ou calcul il a pas besoin de calcul
politique en ce moment il est ministre
de l'Intérieur il a pas de calcul
politique face àch si tu dis il y a un
jeu politique il est dans son rôle
essayer de de de détruire Mélenchon je
vois pas c'est comme si jokovi qui
parlait mal d'un mec qui joue pas au
tennis
vraiment là il est train de t'expliquer
qu'il est obligé de remettre une
protection j'ai dit bah oui
mais voir ce qu' pens téléspectateur
tiens est-ce que tu veux dire un mot
làdessus moi j'ai V j'ai vu le débat
j'ai vu le débat justement avec Madame
CRIF que j'ai trouvé excellent j'ai
trouvé de qualité
madame madamef c'est le
Bou c'est le boucher
[Applaudissements]
cach jeai trouvé super le tweet vraiment
de trop et une chose que je peux dire
c'est que dans les cités honnêtement il
faut pas il faut pas se leurer c'est que
les les mecs de cité ne suivent pas
Mélenchon strictement rien à faire il y
a chose à vraiment aucun souci làd
regard le sonage 74% les G ch Mathilde
Panau critique le fait que l'on donne
une protection policière à
beaucoup il passent leur temps à dire du
mal de la police et en même temps ils
veulent protection
chose che le serpent qui se la queue à
tout de suite on arrive merci à tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
Arve